cette opération choc d'extinction
rébellion en place beauvau aujourd'hui
les militants du mouvement écologiste
ont déversé du faux sont devant l'entrée
du ministère de l'intérieur
certains se sont enchaînés aux grilles
le but protester contre la politique
répressive du gouvernement qui ralentit
selon eux la prise de décision en faveur
de l'écologie
il était entouré les forces de l'ordre
ce qui ne les a pas empêchés de scander
leurs revendications et leurs slogans
non suivi ce temps des millions de morts
ce qui va l'abolir
on fait rien
[Musique]
l'élection pour dénoncer notamment les
violences policières écouter exception
événement a choisi la désobéissance
civile pourquoi parce qu'on estimait que
les pétitions les tribunes il y en a
beaucoup déjà et puis que souvent ça ne
marchait pas il fallait des actions un
peu plus spectaculaires ont été dégoûtés
par les violences policières
ça dure depuis 18 mois dans une
démocratie c'est pas normal et ça dure
et ça dure et là ça vient de reprendre
avec la sortie du confinement
donc premièrement dénoncer ça et dire
que si on apaise pas la société on ne va
pas arriver à faire les réformes qui
sont nécessaires par rapport aux
changements climatiques et à l'effort
mondial de diversité